♪ [upbeat music plays]
Peter Vesterbecka: Yeah, so we
just released our first version
for the biggest platform out there.
So, we released Angry Birds for the web
together with the Chrome team.
So, that's actually now available
in the Chrome Web Store.
So we built this using like
some of the latest HTML features,
so this is all WebGL.
Okay. We also support Canvas for people
that don't have WebGL in their browser.
We used the Google Web Toolkit,
so we built this all in Java.
Then we're using a bunch of
other stuff like the App cache.
So again being in the Chrome Web Store,
we have access to a bit more storage
so we can actually support the complete
Angry Birds game experience
when you're offline as well.
So, there's a lot of cool stuff
that went into this.
Yeah, so we brought this whole
Chrome dimension.
So it's a set of exclusive levels
that are only available in Chrome.
So that's something that
you should definitely check out.
There are seven levels in the Chrome
dimension and they're all very Chrome-y.
00:01:05.542,00:00:00.000